私肇社長
本日をもちまして
止めます
肇社長の口コーナー
今日は弾み冊をです a
グッズのコーナーですあの本当にただの
独り言だと思って聴いてもらえるとすごい
ありがたいですねあの曲過激な表現だっ
たりあの酷い事言うかもしれないすまー的
にはエヴァっておくんですけどもそこには
誰かを教えるよするつもりもないですし何
かを傷つけるとしてるわけじゃないです
本当に何か俺の際にあった心の中の内を
話したいなと思って
もしよかったら聞いてください
嫌な思いするかもしれないからほんとせる
あすまん
よかったら聞いてくれないというちょっと
グ児童が鳴りますあの声を月一で上げて
いいですかまあ本当はが俺の独り言だと
思って聴いててもらえるとしてもやり難い
ですよかったらを付け下さいもう何回目に
なるんだろうなぁほんとごめんまたこいつ
舌てんなって思われたらここまでなんです
けどもみなさん安心してください多分今日
でこの話題は最後になります
前も意見ブツ切れたんですけどもサウナの
話をちょっと細めんねほんとにほんとまじ
込め最後に一回だけさせてくださいもう
これ以降サウナの暗い話はきっとないと
思うんですけどもとりあえずあの昨日の
ツイッターご覧になられた方いらっしゃい
ますでしょうかすごいを2000リ
ツイート入ってるのみなさんありがとう
ございますいろんな意見が飛び交ったん
ですけども6よく黙って入力いるとあと
サラダしてない手を離さないでって書いて
あるのにお話ししちゃう大学生とかおじ
さんたちは文字が読めない赤ちゃんという
ことで大丈夫
時間ジュニアのすいませ処置がオーラせて
いただきました煽らせていただいたという
かも
思ったとおりのこと書いたんですけども
あのまたちょっとサウナですごいしゃべる
人がいたなあという話ですそうねもうあの
正直言っていいですかもう怒るとかそう
いう次元を越えてもう俺や逆にも成長した
離さないでって書いてあるサラダで
しゃべる人たちのおかげであの子か人間と
して成長できましたありがとうございます
もう怒ってないです私安心してくださいな
ので昨日 twitter のこの文章に
も年前いい加減のメッセージとかなくて
もう本当に思った通りです黙って入れとか
サウナでを離さないでって書いてあるの
読めない人とかいるんですよあれ大学生
だったかななんか大学の話だから多分大学
生だと思いますあとおじさんとかも話して
たかな年齢は関係ないんだろうなって
入り口とかにも書いてあるしサウナの湯気
で見えないとか言い訳ができないの入り口
のと真ん中に貼ってあったりするからそう
いうのはやっぱりわからない人たちはいる
んだろうなって入っ思ったかな米もあの
諦めた俺は今年に入ってからも結構されな
いって言ってあの極力頑張ってきたんです
よさだって
まっすぐつけないんじゃないですかマスク
着けずに入るからやっぱり怖いんですよね
あの周りで話してる人とか払ってる人とか
が言うとこのマンボウが出てる時にすら
それしてる人がずーっといて
まあなんか込めて熱い
なんでいろんなお店飲食店が20時に
しまってみんながマスクつけてるのか全然
わかってないんだなっていうであの俺も
極力あの頑張って注意してきたつもりなん
ですよてかこれされないかな人からすると
わかりずらいですねちょっと簡単に立て
ましょうマスクしてはいけない図書館って
いうイメージアのサウナって静かな場所な
んですよさ皆オブザイヤー2021が言い
ますのでかなり説得力あると思います
サラダの子についてはそこはちょっときい
てるサンって基本的に静かに入る場所です
それではそれかといっても過言じゃないと
今図書館でしゃべっている時がつりますよ
ね集中力だったりそれをずっとしている人
はいるなっていう感覚かつマスクしては
いけない図書館なのでもうこの子の中この
子ランナーは何度かしようってなっている
時に図書館でマスクせずぺ差別ペペと喋っ
てる人たち月
と言って頑張ってあの注意したり後輩とか
とちょっと静かにしてもらえませんかって
言ってきたつもりなんですけど
減らないですねもう減らないずやめない
もう昨日そのついたした原因の大きな1個
の理由としては俺じゃないんですけど注意
されてたんですよその一つべされていたの
にその5分後にまたもうをしゃべってて
ああもうこの人たちは話もできないんだ
この人たち
静かにするという意味もわかんないんだっ
ていう
すごいよ
参りましたというものが張ってあっても人
に言われてもわかんない人直せないもう今
このご時世がどういう状況で何でお店が
20時に閉まっているかとかその3案に
いる人たちがどういう気持ちがもう何にも
わかんないんだろうなぁと思って
もう
ああこれは赤ちゃんだと思って本当には
怒りに落ちない人はボケで起こってない
ですよあの
仕方ない人たちがいるんだなと思っては
決められたルールを守れない人達って
やっぱり世の中でいるんだなと思ったよう
な僕はあきらめたんですけどこういう状況
にもかかわらず部分が折れない夫なーと
かってたくさんいるんだなぁと思いました
あのはかね俺がちょっとか像なのかもしれ
ないね今サウナーブームと言われていて
本当にたくさんの人がサーブのに入って
いらっしゃいましてで俺はギリギリブーム
もう爆発的ブームの手前ぐらいにサウナに
目覚めたから静かなサーブの知ってるわけ
ですよこれが始まる前にさあだというもの
をしてみんが静かに全く話せなって言っ
てるわけじゃないけども必要最低限の会話
に止めてし柄にサウナを楽しいに柄に休憩
して静かにととのあの俺の好きなサブなっ
てそれだったんでともその頃なじゃなくで
もちょっとサウナでぺちゃくちゃ
ぺちゃくちゃしゃべっているのは個人的に
はどうかなと思いますしそれに加えてさ
もうあのお店種百歩譲ってお店が沐浴とか
サウンド室内でしゃべらないといって書い
てねだから俺も2位しないですよそこまで
お兄ちゃんないから床までは何かお
せっかいな人じゃないから外でマスクして
ない人見たら
マスクしてないなぁすればいいのに暗い
思いますけど注意もしないしもしその
サラダにさらしてないで話せなっていう
ルールがなければをそらさないでしゃべる
も強だと思いますそれが嫌な人はもうそろ
さらにいかなければいいしけど
話すなって書いてあるサーブがで話す人
たち
もうお手上げです何だろうなぁ悲しいな
行かれている悲しい気持ちがすごいです俺
たばもう2回ぐらいこのサウナでさあ
うるさい人に怒ってるわけですよもうこの
頃の時をかませればいいのに良い
喋っちゃう人が入ってさあそれも知らない
わけじゃその人のことちょっと色んな
リプレイ機転で応えたいほどに応えていく
んですけども室内でコラボしている
ユーチューバーはまあ仕事だからある程度
仕方ないとして普通に飲食でも木植誘電の
に喋ってる人居るけどそのプライ別にいい
と思うけどなこれが僕も同じ感じちょっと
くらいの話で良いと思いますてかの仕切り
とかことでアクリル板とかあるとちょっと
あのマジにはなるかなと思いますまあ俺は
テニスの時もマスクつけてるけどがえらい
ねてかユーチューバーもますつけろよ
コラボするとき中バーのコラボって最低の
こと知ってるわけじゃ相手がどんな生活し
てるとか不特定多数の人が合ってない
ちょっとか分かるんですけどサウナに感謝
誰がいるかわかんないんですよ
めちゃくちゃ人混みでますかねあるって
言った人かもしれないし居酒屋でいろんな
人とお酒飲んでぺちゃくちゃ喋った後に猿
が来てる人もいるかもしれない誰か分から
ない人なんですよさらにいる人たち
ユーチューバーのコラボせますくっ言え
ないのとは
う訳が違うのかなって僕はちょっと感じ
ました次回ありがとうございますそんな
文句言うなら行くなよって思います
そうね
確かにすまない文句を言ってるけどあ書い
てくれてるわ2書があるのにそれを破る人
のことに文句を言って何が悪いんですか
社長はまだを守っていますかありがとう
ございますそのとおりですねサウナの中で
静かに入っいうルールがなければ俺も何も
言わないご時世的に静かにして欲しいけど
側が自由ですよただお店のルールとして
さあこれもビッグだよって言われるけどさ
喋らないっていう風なサウナんだからこそ
言ってるんですよ喋っていたそういう例が
ないさんだったらあのごもっともな意見
ですけど話しちゃダメなサーブ度に入って
さあ話している人がいていく内容は
ちょっとなんか
たとルール守って入ってる人たちが
かわいそうだなって僕が思ってしまいまし
たってかそういうとほとんどなんですよ
なんかがよく行くさんあるんですけれども
基本的にはほんと素敵な人いっぱいです
サウラー-1もうさらに入ってる間ずっと
静かにしてる人たくさんいて自分も
もちろんやなんですけどさなんか喋られた
で指摘が吊るしこの人たちが頃なかったら
どうしようとすごい思うんですけどもなん
かグールをちゃんと守ってたお店を利用し
ている人たちが大勢いるのに一部のまん
かつはまあこっちはヴィランとここで
ヴィランと呼ばせてくださ一部のヴィラン
たちのせいでまず目にルール守ってる人
たちが馬鹿を見る世界だなんだと悲しい
なぁってあ地面は思ってしまいましたうん
ほんとが俺の木に c 席なのかもしれ
ない本堂ネオンの気にしすぎだったら
ほんとあの俺の一人 bot だと思って
聞き流していてほしいんですけどその喋っ
てる人が本当に多いんですよこのマンボウ
が発令されている時にもお店の人たちも
頑張ってくれてるんですよずっとサウナに
お店の人がいるわけにもいかないし俺も
最近は自分に注意するよりを店の人に言っ
たほうがいいなとってお店の人にサウナ室
内でずっとしゃべっている人たちがいるん
ですけどなんとかならないですかって言っ
て注意していただいたりしますけどもう
帯紐頑張ってくれてるのに留まらないと
いうことは結局もその一つの意識の問題だ
と思ってでその意識が変わんないっていう
かもう話がわからない注意しては分から
ない話だって書いてあっても話しちゃう
バブーそりゃもうあのヴィランたちは
バブルだなと思いまして昨日はちょっと
さすがにもこれはダメだって思っちゃっ
たっすねそのヴィランたちのせいで俺が粉
になってもいやだからさもちろんルール
守って入ってる人みんなそうですけど微分
タッチ頃に当たったらどうするコロナじゃ
ないにしてもすごい不快な思い知っている
よう真面目に入っている人たちはがって
思っちゃってなんかもあの俺もは神になっ
たもう1周待っても注意するのやめようっ
て思ってちょっとここで選任させて
ください
私は
もう
サウダーに行くのやめま
はいもうやめはソントンも無理無理あほ
らしい赤ちゃんたちを注意するのもアホ
らしいしてそれで何が自分に何かあった
ときもすごい家達ちょっとねぇ
人間に希望を持ち次たのかもしれな俺は
さすがにどこかでそのサウナとか図書館と
かさ静かにすべき場所のルールを守るん
だろうなって心の動画で人限定的なものだ
と思ってたんですけどまだもちろん席でし
たなんて素敵じゃないってわけじゃない
ですしほとんど体はほんといい人達なん
ですよめっちゃいい人そういうごく一部の
人たちのせいでみんな嫌な思いしてるのは
ちょっとも見てらんないというか
注意してもこれたぶんこの人たち減らない
んだろうなと思って私肇社長は最近はもう
俺の支えと言っても過言ではないちょっと
ポロナーが落ち着くまでサブのニックのは
もうやめようと思います誰も悪くないです
すみませんちゃんと注意書きしている
そして注意してくれる店員さんお店も偉い
ですしてルールを守って静かにサーバに
はいてる人たちは偉いですおじさんや大人
の皮をかぶったアインのことも見えない
注意されてもわからない部分が楽しければ
すべてをって女はかちゃんたちもバブが部
言ってて偉いですちょっとあのここまで話
が分からないというか何言っても通じない
人間っていうのをいるんだなっていうのが
なんかここ最近本と思ったねすごいよ本当
にすごいと思うだってされだろだかみんな
静かにしているのにそのほんの23人の
大学生集団と話してるんですね大学生がつ
に割れて言ってるわけじゃないでしょその
場で話せる大学生たちが
ヴィラそうねもう頃だじゃなくても本来
サウナって静かであるべきだと思うんで
そもそもなんて俺去らないいくかって言っ
たさあお店なさんだってばいいんですよね
質が全然違うメッツ気持ちいいから行って
いいんですけどもまぁ俺を見つけコロナに
なりたくないしなんかもう何言っても
わからない人はわからないんだなーと思っ
て
始めば諦めましたもう所な落ち着くまで
ちょっとがまんすればいいのにそれができ
ないとわー
バルーンそれもビビったのかさ人殿その
ツイッターで何か見てるとさ結構同じよう
な感覚を持ってる人が多くてサラダだけ
じゃなくて岩盤浴とかで後電車とかどうな
んだろ電車ってまでもにご時世的に
しゃべっちゃダメなようなまぁでちゃっと
大きく違うのは最後はもう俺の行ってるし
た促す話なっていうルールがあるから
ルールを破って水をズーム100で破っ
エリートが悪いと思うんでただその破る人
がも後を絶たないんで私は心の落ち着く
まではサラダもう栄冠とこって感じです何
か逆にここまで来ると音が文字読める自分
を偉いんじゃないかと思ってきた文字読ん
で静かにって書いてあったら静かにできる
はずにえらいンスっていうもう口ねもう
なんか注意喚起とかあのっと超えてすっ
げーお寿司なんとかなんかやらそうにして
いる大学生もいるんじゃなくて思いました
あの1個も感じがして欲しくないのは今と
ごく一部の人なんですそういうことする人
たちそれ以外の寒ガーさんは本当に静かに
丁寧にさんが利用してばなさるなら場所
づくりしてくれてると思うんですけども黒
5分のそういう最近サウナに入り始めたの
かなもうキュッでもわかんないんだったら
何しても仕方ないなと思って
分かり合えない人間もいるんだなっていう
のはなんでガッツポーズした離しても
分かり合えない人間はいるんだって言う
びらんがいるんだっていうのを今回なんで
このマンボでてから余計みんな気使うか
なぁとってさんが入ってたけど結局そう
いう人はたくないもう全然5人制も関係
なくルールも関係なくて話しちゃう人いる
んだなって思いました今日ツイートなんか
炎上スタートがなんか結構言われるんです
けど逆にインズてほしいは炎上して
いろんな人に飛ぶんだからもう全然それで
いいやって感じです
俺はさと言いましたマーサ撮りましたさ
とりました俺が行かなければいいだけの話
でしたちょっと心当たりある方は今一度
サウナってどういう場所だったっけそして
この羽画面には何て書いてあるんだろう
マスクしてなくて密室で話すと今何が
起こっちゃうんだろうあれ周りの人を見る
と嫌な顔してるぞお友達と来たりする
テンション上がるのわかるんですけども今
一度今のおかげている日本の状況周りの人
見てみてはいかがでしょうか
ユニさんだとか
あっ
[音楽]
はぁ
blh r